the vaccines work so well and enough
people have gotten them
that the cdc has announced
no more outdoor masks in most situations
for vaccinated people now if that sounds
underwhelming
or if your reaction is you know most a
lot of the countries already been doing
that
these guidelines of course are for
people who are following cdc guidelines
if you've not been following them all
along
then you don't really care what the cdc
says you're probably not getting
vaccinated either
you're probably you probably have been
letting it rip but for those of us who
care what the cdc says
and who have been following uh joe
biden's uh
uh agreement with cdc guidelines
remember these aren't biden's guidelines
they are just joe biden
saying i will listen to what the health
experts say the cdc
yesterday announced that outdoor mask
wearing
uh really is not necessary in
most situations now it's very carefully
written
americans who are fully vaccinated
meaning two weeks
after your last dose whether it's one
dose or two doses two weeks after the
last dose at least actually with j and j
maybe longer
if you're fully vaccinated against
coronavirus you no longer need to wear a
mask outdoors
while walking running hiking biking
alone or in a small group
including with members of your own
household masks are still necessary
in crowded outdoor venues like sports
stadiums that's what the cdc
has said joe biden coming out and
announcing the same thing
the cdc stopped short of saying if
you're vaccinated
you just never need a mask outdoors they
say that
it's still conceivably possible that you
could transmit coronavirus
and that with unknown vaccination levels
in crowds
uh it's safer to wear a mask even if
vaccinated in a big crowd
now i think this makes perfect sense
unfortunately
there are some doom and gloomers who are
furious and we were live streaming joe
biden announcing this yesterday and i
had people saying
david you can still pass it even if
vaccinated well
yes you can but uh transmission is
reduced by more than 90 percent
and outdoors it's almost zero
pre-vaccination
dr rasheesh jaw believes one out of a
thousand cases were transmitted outdoors
that's before anyone was vaccinated
uh you are really talking about
percentages and a risk level that is
lower than the flu when you're talking
about an increasingly vaccinated
outdoor situation i've been following
the guidelines so even though from the
beginning i thought
if i'm biking on the bike path i don't
need a mask
but after getting some dirty looks yes
the judgment worked on me
and i put the mask on when biking or
when running or whatever
we are now being told very clearly by
the cdc
that certainly at least vaccinated
people
do not need to do that now the cdc
director rochelle walensky
emphasized a bigger interpretation
than the narrow wording of the cdc
saying quote we no longer feel that the
vaccinated people require masks outdoors
other than large public venues period
and
uh one really interesting thing is that
the cdc
has also put out a um sort of pictograph
that shows a list of activities the risk
level if you are unvaccinated and the
risk level if you are fully vaccinated
the risk level for fully vaccinated
people is color-coded green
meaning low risk for every activity
including going to crowded outdoor
events
the venue and the recommendation may
still be to put a mask on in that
situation even if vaccinated
but the cdc making clear if you're
vaccinated the risk level
for a big concert is low the risk level
for going
inside at restaurants is still low now
of course it will continue to be lower
as more and more people are vaccinated
if you individually have a higher risk
profile
then that may not be something you want
to do right away and we're going to talk
about that later
in my segment about joe rogan's recent
comments but
hopefully the point here is that
hopefully this will encourage more
people to
want to get vaccinated that is
increasingly an issue
that we are dealing with in the united
states while many countries are still
having major
supply issues with vaccines in the u.s
increasingly the problem is lack of
demand uh it's tr
it's actually tragic so many countries
desperate to get vaccines they haven't
yet been able to get
in the u.s more and more states are
going to just show up
you don't even need an appointment and
they're still not filling every slot so
hopefully the word from the cdc and
biden
that the masks can come off for
vaccinated people in
almost every scenario will encourage
more people to want to get vaccinated
the counterpoint is if you still don't
want to get vaccinated you probably
don't care what the cdc says about masks
and that
certainly uh is a source of concern
let's now talk about some of the
reaction from the media to joe biden's
announcement
of what the cdc has determined regarding
masks
one of our sponsors today is blue blocks
i spend a lot of time because of my work
looking at a computer screen and
peer-reviewed studies have shown
that the blue light that comes from
screens can actually lead to certain
types of
eye strain and even damage or blurred
vision headaches dry
watery eyes blue blocks fixes this by
filtering
out the blue light and unlike other
cheap blue light glasses
the effectiveness of blue blocks glasses
are backed up
by evidence and they're built under
optics laboratory conditions
these are my blue blocks glasses i like
how they look they have over 40
different styles to choose from
i really have noticed a big difference
where i'm no longer
getting that eye strain and headaches
from the computer
screen because of the blue blocks
glasses they have
prescription versions and
non-prescription and readers
they have something for every need and
blue blocks
is giving you 20 off when you go to
blueblocks.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is under this video and you'll get free
shipping on orders over 115 dollars